we know what present value is in theory
but what i haven't given you
is um why do we care about this like
under what circumstances this is a
meaningful question to ask
so i'm going to give you a scenario and
then we're going to see how this present
value table
and present values in general it's going
to help us okay so i want you to imagine
you're a business owner okay you're all
business owners
and you want to make a um you want to
open a new store
okay now just to make the numbers a
little bit simpler i'm going to keep
them relatively low
let's suppose to open a new location
for your business that's growing it's
it's expanding um what's what's
something that
is expanding and covered because most
things are shrinking face masks okay you
run a face mask business
or like a clear perspex business and
everyone's buying that for their shops
right okay so you're like uh it's time
to open a new store it's the right time
it's gonna cost me a hundred thousand
dollars
to open this new store okay because you
gotta
you gotta hire people you gotta get all
the um goods in
you've gotta deck it all out posters
whatever okay so 100 grand
that's how much it costs you to start up
but you can make some predictions
because you've been watching the current
economic climate
you can make some predictions about the
estimated income
right um or i should say how much profit
you're going
to make if you open this business up
it'll cost you something but you'll get
something back
okay so let's suppose what number did i
come up with let's suppose you got
18 000 profit every year
so this is uh you've already paid all
your workers
you've already paid like the cost price
to make these new masks
whatever after all of that you come out
the end
with 18 000 profit okay so this is
really good
right now what i'm interested in is
let's suppose
i want to be able to pay off like i've
got to borrow money to do this
right i've got to borrow money to start
this store suppose the bank says to me
hey
you're going to pay this off i'm not
going to give you forever i'm gonna give
you six years
six years to repay me this loan
okay so i'm like okay i need to work out
is this a
is it worth me opening this store am i
going to make enough profit
to be able to pay this off over time
this loan that i took out
so the loan is going to be how much i
have to borrow to start this store
right so 18 000 is how much i'm going to
profit
and i should say that's um that's
actually every year let's say okay
yeah i should have said 18 000 per annum
over the course of six years okay
so year one i'm gonna make this much and
then year two i'm also gonna make this
much
and so on and so on okay yeah so what
i'm trying to work out is
uh am i going to come out ahead is this
a worthwhile thing to do to start this
business
okay now you're going to be able to work
out uh you know is this helpful or not
firstly by saying
18 000 times six roughly speaking like
that's about 20 000 right
what's it roughly gonna be 120 roughly a
bit less
so you're like that looks good right at
least just on the face of it putting the
money underneath my my bed and not doing
anything with it
but we can do better than that can't we
like once we've got profits coming in
what would i do with them would i put
them under my bed
no i'm going to reinvest them right so
in other words i'm going to get a future
value
for this thing right so have a look at
your table from yesterday
okay let's suppose we can invest at
i think the example that we did
yesterday was um four percent
interest okay we actually
hand generated this with a geometric
progression um four percent
six years so go and find that number
from memory it's like 6.6
something has anyone got the number
there that's that's the one fantastic so
our future value of this is going to be
our eighteen thousand dollars
and then i multiply it by the
appropriate future value factor right
which is
6.6330 i think
that's what you just said right and we
got that from the future value table can
someone go ahead
and reach for their calculator and tell
me what that lands on
i'm just confused i don't think there's
gonna be a demand for it if you're doing
something seasonal like
masks i hate to refer to it
like i'm hoping that it disappears sure
next six years would you still be making
the same amount of
profit that isn't that is an excellent
question to ask and i place
entirely the blame on me just running
with the first example i got for a
business
let's just assume i accepted the offer
um let's say it isn't a seasonal thing
we can reasonably
uh reliably predict some amount of
income okay
what do we get 119
is that right yeah yeah okay and and
394 394 flat
absolutely cool okay so we were in the
ballpark we know this was about right
okay we expected oh it's going to be
around 120 000. so at least we know
we've punched our numbers into the
calculator
accurately okay so this is all looking
good
it looks promising doesn't it right
here's what we had to
borrow to do this here's how much we end
up with at the end of six years so
everything looks
fantastic there's just um it's just one
teeny little problem
right you know how you are earning this
money and you're like oh it's in the
bank it's earning me interest this is
all great okay
we haven't accounted for the fact that
we had to get this money
from the beginning right we had to
borrow that
and guess what if you can earn interest
at this amount
you're also going to get charged
interest at this amount okay it goes
it's sort of
two-way sword goes both ways okay so
what i need to do is i
need to work out the original loan right
it started out at a hundred thousand
dollars but i had to hold on to that
loan
over the course of these six years that
i own this business right
so therefore over those six years they
have earned
six years of interest interest is uh
1.04
right that's going to add me on and i'm
going to
raise it to the power of six because it
happens six times okay
what's this sum you know go ahead and
evaluate it for me
pretty sure it starts with a one but i'm
not very confident after that
takers anyone there
do you do you not all know your 1.04
times tables i'm disappointed
okay who's who's got him he's got it
he's uh thanks thanksgiving i'll take
that 126 thousand
531 and
90 cents cool thank you very much okay
so here we have landed on a problem do
you see what the problem is
okay our expected profits are here
right which is like cool that's happy
times greater than one hundred thousand
but that original one hundred thousand
doesn't just stay a hundred thousand
you've borrowed it so they're going to
charge you like a mortgage okay
so the original loan that's the interest
charge
so that's yeah that's the money that
you're in debt correct that's exactly
right this is the money i'm in debt and
because
this quantity here is greater than all
the profits put together
yeah that's the profit right so you can
see how i'm in some trouble right
even though this initially looks quite
attractive right when you go ahead and
work this
out you realize you're in trouble yeah
you're in deficit exactly right
now do you notice do you notice this
took us two steps two steps
future value and then you compare it
with um what happened to the loan that
allowed you to get that future value
but if you now flow over to your present
value table we can do this in not two
steps but one
okay instead of saying go to the future
value and then also the
loans value in the future we can just go
straight to
the present value think about what your
profit's going to do
and go to your new table that i've asked
you to pick up for today
that eighteen thousand dollars which we
estimated right
if we go to the present value table what
will it tell us
it is compared to today right and now um
i did look this up but i can't remember
what time i had i think it starts with
five right can someone find me the right
row in the right column
this is uh what is it it's six years
four percent interest
six time periods i should say because it
could be months or whatever
five point two four two one thank you
okay
again let's go ahead and evaluate but
i'm
already immediately suspicious because i
know 18 times five is 90
and like a little bit so i'm like
already worried right so this is going
to be
has anyone got there
94 357
and 80 thank you very much okay so you
can see here
rather than go this sort of long way
around and consider everything in the
future
all i need to do is say this is how much
it's gonna cost me this is how much it's
worth
this is like today present value if it's
gonna cost me this much
and this is how much i'm gonna get back
i already don't need to think about the
future right that's the whole point
of present value and literally the
entire stock market is driven by these
calculations that everyone's making
should i buy this
or not should i sell it or not yeah is
it going to be advantageous to me
um or not does that make sense
so um practically speaking we use these
did i turn it off no i muted it we use
these
tables in exactly the same way that we
use future value tables but they ask a
different question
they're asking about now okay and allow
us to make decisions on the best of that